conectamos con nuestro enviado especial
andrés suárez jaramillo quien se
encuentra en uno de los puntos de
concentración de indocumentados o junto
con aurora o ayude en cámara andrés
gracias y en qué punto se encuentra la
caravana qué detalle se tienen en su
cuarto día de recorrido por el sur de
méxico hola nos encontramos aquí en uno
de los sitios puntos de concentración de
wii la caravana se encuentra fragmentada
y se encuentra fragmentada porque son
diferentes los grupos que vienen por
este documento una forma migratoria
múltiple es el documento con el cual se
le otorga un estado de legalidad a los
migrantes para que puedan continuar su
recorrido por méxico
el organizador el coordinador de esta
caravana que habla de más de 15.000 de
los migrantes pues en este momento tiene
planeado que una vez los migrantes con
este documento puedan despegar en
diferentes buses en la noche de este
jueves con rumbo a ciudad de méxico para
después ir hacia la frontera al sur de
los eeuu
andrés se ha mencionado que la caravana
podría ser una de las más grandes en la
historia de las migraciones y eeuu que
testimonios ha encontrado a usted de los
migrantes ya que le apuestan en su
travesía
bueno son muchas las historias de vida
que se pueden encontrar en esta caravana
vemos por ejemplo esta mañana ha
conversado con venezolanos que cruzaron
desde necoclí asia hasta panamá la selva
el tapón del darién y en este punto
muchos de ellos se formaron en familia y
amigos porque enfrentaron el desafío de
la muerte otros migrantes como los
centroamericanos por ejemplo de
nicaragua se escapan de la represión que
existe en este país por cuenta del
gobierno de daniel ortega y muchos de
ellos nunca más volverán de manera que
es uno de los puntos más críticos ha
sido aquí méxico donde ha sido tan
difícil encontrar una solución para
encontrar un estatus de legalidad que
les permita estar unos días acá pero
todos tienen la vista puesta en la
frontera sur de los eeuu en el estado de
texas para atravesar el río el río bravo
por dos puntos claves uno piensa negras
y el otro
un lugar que queda justo al lado de
piedras negras que les permite a los
migrantes cruzar atravesar el río y
encontrarse con sus familias en eeuu